greetings hot satan lovers and welcome
to episode 4 of american horror story
apocalypse where we take a deep dive
into the episode and explore
some of the mysteries and theories
within so fold your towels and clean
your crock pots ladies and gentlemen
we're in for one hell of a ride the
episode begins with tatan that's
satan plus tate recounting his childhood
with robot mom
but in all actuality this is his real
mother who mead is based off
they say a prayer to the dark lord
before starting their meal and
end it by saying nema which is amen
spelled backwards
notice langdon's hair here looks awfully
like tates from season one
also hinting that his real mother is
somehow connected with jessica lange
she explains that she killed her first
three husbands for the insurance
policies and it's just great to see a
beautiful mother-son bonding moment over
prayers to the dark lord and talk of
murder
behind her is a picture of befomet i'm
probably butchering that name
a symbol supposedly worshiped by the
knights templar in the late 1300s
which was later adopted by the satanist
movement in the 1800s occultist alistair
crowley referred to befomet as the
divine androgen
an androgynous being composed of both
male and female parts
which hints at michael langdon who if
you remember when he's questioned by
venable in episode 2
hints that he might not actually be a
man we'll come back to this point a bit
back in real time langdon tells me that
he needs someone to help
rebuild this world and meed for the
first time
feels like she's found her place she's
come a long way in just a few minutes
but that's when langdon senses the
witches we're back where we left off
with cordelia having risen mallory dina
and coco
they were under an identity spell which
cordelia put on them for their own
protection
because they're special and she needs
them for the upcoming war
dina isn't having it and madison tells
her as if you could defeat anyone with
that backwards voodoo [ __ ] hinting that
she is somehow related to marie laveau's
voodoo witchcraft from season three
langdon confronts them and tells them
they can't win before myrtle reveals
that he is a warlock
but is he we'll get into that in a bit
we then flash back three years to
warlock hogwarts
kids chant igneme acende latin meaning
to burn or ignite
a level 1 student arrives late and is
chastised by behold
chablis one of the teachers at the
school we'll learn that there are four
levels of warlock level 1 being the
weakest
chablis tells the student if he's late
he'll wind up at the magic castle doing
card tricks like neil patrick harris
a nod to neil's character in season 4
freak show where he plays a magician
they also chant x-forma mutate facti
sunfigura nova which is latin for
change form become a new shape chablis
tells them their power is woven into
their dna
does that mean timmy and emily who were
told they have special dna in episode 1
are also which in warlock they turn a
bunch of perfectly good gems into an
aluminum ball making it the easiest
aluminum ball
challenge look how big this thing is
right now
the scientist from jurassic park comes
in and tells chablis they've been
summoned
here we meet the two other teachers john
henry moore and the grand chancellor
ariel who is coincidentally named after
an archangel
the teachers watch a video of langdon
training the world's greatest
contortionists while discussing his
powers
are his powers his own or are they more
demonic as john henry suggests
the warlocks we learn are not evil in
fact they don't even want dark energy
around them ariel suggests this boy
could be the one the prophecy suggested
the one they've been looking for the
alpha the warlocks version of a supreme
being so powerful he'd be able to pass
the test of the seven wonders
the same tests zoe madison misty and
queenie undergo in the finale of season
three
if his powers are real he could supplant
the supreme ariel springs langdon from
jail and tells him he's a warlock
langdon tells him he got in jail for
defending his mother when we get this
lovely flashback
mrs satan wants a goat's head for
incantations and accuses the butcher of
discrimination for her religious beliefs
this also happened in real life when a
group of satanists attempted to put a
statue of baphomet next to the ten
commandments
and when they were told to take it down
said it was religious discrimination
langdon does his best arthur meme and
uses his telekinetic power to stab the
guy with butcher knives
the irony of a butcher being butchered
ariel tells michael his life's about to
begin and uses his warlock power to open
the cell door
they're stopped by an officer but ariel
uses his powers once again
he's innocent of all charges i'm taking
him with me
they escape but langdon kills the
officer hinting the malevolence within
him
mead is there somehow knowing her boy
will make her proud someday
ariel explains that in 2014 cordelia
outed the magic users to the world they
became discriminated and had to move
underground because
locals threw molotov cocktails into
their school michael is welcome but it
looks like john henry still has his
doubts
one month in langdon is evaluated by the
warlocks he is to be assigned his level
and we learn the teachers are
all level three a level four would make
them as powerful as the female supreme
and there's never been a level four
warlock the level one test involves
scrying
the ability to see things on a
reflective surface he must find a book
the new adam and eve by nathaniel
hawthorne a story about how after the
destruction of earth god created a new
adam and eve to start over
he's tasked to find out where the book
was hidden but goes one step further and
actually retrieves it from the mirror
the next task involves
salier perspacium latin for jump through
space
he is easily able to dodge the brick and
knife and is found on the ceiling just
like the rubber man in episode two
finally sterocedium or snowfall
not only is he able to conjure snow but
something takes over him
the wind and cold becomes too unbearable
for baldwin who can't breathe
ariel stops him and is pleased if he can
learn to control these powers there's no
limit to how high he can soar
at dinner the teachers talk about
langdon being the most powerful warlock
they've ever seen
they're grooming him to take on the
witches only john henry is the one who
has doubts there's malevolence to his
magic
leading me to believe he is not the
alpha nor a warlock his powers stem from
satan himself
he's a false prophet also if you can do
this
sign me up for warlock school they then
toast to the moment
everything changes we're back in the
coven [ __ ] and zoe is now a teacher
mallory is one of the students and turns
the rose into blue butterflies
zoe even says her bloodline goes all the
way back to salem
salem being the location of the infamous
witch trials of the late 1600s in which
over 600 young women were accused of
being witches
19 of them executed by hanging myrtle
informs cordelia and zoe that the
warlocks have called an emergency
council meeting at the hawthorne school
for exceptional young men
the same last name of the author of the
book langdon was tasked to retrieve in
the scrying test
at the council meeting ariel explains
that the boys powers are so impressive
they match those of the supreme
the witches scoff and cordelia reminds
him that in all of history no man has
ever approached the level of supreme
men aren't equal to women when it comes
to magical ability
testosterone is a known inhibitor
impeding access to the ethereal realm
once again hinting that langdon is not
male or at least
not fully ariel wants the witches to
administer the test of the seven wonders
but cordelia won't do it because she'd
be condemning this boy to his death
after all she lost misty by
administering the test too early
and let's all say a big hello to queenie
who's been trapped in the hotel cortez
the setting for season five she's been
in a never-ending card game with march a
serial killer and builder of the cortez
cordelia explains that the hotel wasn't
haunted rather it was a doorway to hell
where the devil reigns
her spells were useless in that hotel
hinting that when the witches fight the
demonic forces their spells won't work
or will be severely weakened
cordelia's efforts to save queenie end
in failure and she considers it her
worst failure as supreme
as the supreme in charge of caring for
all people meaning both the witches and
warlocks she denies giving the test to
langdon
fearing his safety ariel says she's just
scared of the alpha the one to bring the
end of female domination
a role reversal what's going on in
society today the push for equality
the metoo movement and even cordelia
using the phrase
time's up but in this world the females
are dominant and the men are the ones
striving for equality langdon is
possessed and draws the hotel cortez
something is taking control of him
beckoning him there and soon we see him
come to the rescue of queenie
to do what her supreme couldn't march
seems to sense his power
probably because he knows what's
controlling michael he immediately knows
she won't be back
saying solitaire it is able to get her
out langan says
there's one person left to get madison
works customer returns in her own
eternal hell
she's undervalued overworked and worst
of all unrecognized she's even cattle
prodded by her boss
randall i even love the never-ending
line of returns
langdon comes to claim her soul and save
her from this hell
madison hose it up telling him he's a
snack and how terrible that they're
always out of stock of personal
massagers
before queenie arrives to convince
madison to come there's work to do
and he needs both of them but what he
really needs is to prove a point that
his abilities are extremely powerful
langdon arrives with madison and queenie
and let me just say for people who've
just returned from the netherworld they
look fine as hell
cordelia faints as the witches reunite
langdon basking in the knowledge he was
able to do what the others could not so
what can we expect from the next few
episodes
we'll likely see two separate timelines
one the past learning how langdon took
over as alpha
and witnessing the birth of the
cooperative and two
the current timeline the battle between
the witches and satan
will michael bring back misty and will
jon henry moore defect to the witches
we'll have to stay tuned for next
episode hey everyone i hope you liked
this video
if you enjoyed it please give it a like
and subscribe i'm planning on doing the
whole season so i hope you'll stick with
me i also have a new twitter where you
can find my video release schedule
or just ask me questions so give me a
follow at think story yt
and last but not least daddy loves you
very much